For this quiz, I want you to
experience the web without images.
Install Lynx and ChromeVox.
You can find some links
in the instructor notes.
Once you do,
visit an image heavy website.
Ask yourself, what is it like
experiencing the web without images, and
try listening to a site with ChromeVox.
If all you had was ChromeVox,
could you figure out what
the images were trying to tell you?
Making your website accessible to
everybody is incredibly important,
because not only does it
make you a good person,
it means that more people
can experience your website.
So, when you check this
check box down here,
it means that you are promising to
use all attributes responsibly.